[Musique]
nous ne pouvons pas faire sans l'union
européenne aujourd'hui pour nous
renforcer dans la mondialisation c'est
une certitude absolue et nous avons
besoin de la force que nous donne ce
marché unique qui a été construit pour
pouvoir peser face aux géants que sont
aujourd'hui la chine par exemple où les
états unis je ne confonds pas à ces deux
pôles mais une chose est certaine il
faut que nous puissions nous renforcée
par l'alliance de nos états au sein de
ce marché unique cela étant dit
malheureusement aujourd'hui l'europe à
céder à une forme de naïveté et cette
naïveté est coupable parce qu'elle
fragilise nos entreprises et nos emplois
par la concurrence déloyale que nous
leur imposant trop souvent en laissant
entrer sur notre marché unique sans
aucune exigence de réciprocité des
entreprises internationales qui viennent
faire du profit sur nos marchés
prenons un exemple tout simple l'europe
c'est pour le pib
20 % réalisés sur les marchés publics
nos marchés publics sont ouverts à 95%
ce n'est pas du tout le cas évidemment
de nos partenaires commerciaux il faut
donc que nous exigions une réciprocité
et la nécessité pour l'avenir de
l'europe c'est de rééquilibrer la
mondialisation va revenir faisant de ce
marché comme frondeurs mondialisation un
premier pardon mais c'est pas qu'elle se
sente déclassés ou maltraitées c'est
qu'elles le sont et elles le sont
effectivement par les travers du projet
européen tel que nous l'avons construit
aujourd'hui elles le sont par le fait
que la politique agricole commune qui a
été l'une des plus grandes réussites de
l'europe qui nous a fait sortir de la
pénurie alimentaire
aujourd'hui cette politique agricole
commune que malheureusement nous avons
laissé que le gouvernement a laissé se
fragiliser dans les instances
européennes
ce que si c'est exact c'est tout
d'accord toutes ces années sur le modèle
agricole que vous défendiez à bruxelles
terminé
je disais tout à l'heure de mettre en
oeuvre cette politique alcool qui soit
vraiment commune c'est à dire qui impose
les mêmes règles à tous à l'intérieur du
marché unique et qui deuxièmement et je
pense qu'on sera d'accord pour le dire
qui impose cette réciprocité qui fait
que nous n'avons pas le droit de fixer
des règles à nos agriculteurs que nous
ne fixons pas à se dire sur le marché ce
qui est certain c'est que la droite ne
s'est sans doute pas en effet assez
préoccupé de la question écologique qui
est une question fondamentale
on a parfois accusée d'être conservateur
je crois que ce terme est impropre pour
décrire les grands défis qui sont devant
nous mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
l'écologie est peut-être une
préoccupation conservatrice nous avons
et c'est notre première responsabilité à
transmettre un monde qui soit encore
vivables c'est une nécessité absolue
la droite s'en est préoccupé d'ailleurs
pardonnez moi de le dire mais je crois
que le grenelle de l'environnement a été
un moment important
d'abord pour la prise de conscience sur
ensuite pour l'action gouvernementale
sur ces questions environnementales
c'est moi mais revenons heureusement
revenons maintenant peut-être un instant
sur la question de l'agriculture sur la
question de l'agriculture
il y a effectivement une vraie tragédie
dans notre pays et je pense que nous
partageons tous ce constat et cette
tragédie là nous n'en sortirons que par
un vrai pragmatisme pardonnez moi
monsieur glucksmann mais je suis désolé
on ne peut pas dire aujourd'hui que
l'aide européenne soit toxique
notre famille politique elle considère
que la politique agricole commune est
nécessaire pour la survie des
agriculteurs ont joué l'un vers la
transformer il faut effectivement sans
aucun doute l'orienter de façon plus
fine mais nous avons aussi besoin
d'abord donner moi de vous le dire c'est
les propos des modes vous le verrez
aussi nous avons aussi besoin de ne pas
rester uniquement à un modèle de
circuits courts ou d'agriculture
biologique même des agriculteurs passer
au bio sont les premiers à le dire la
france elle a un climat tempéré elle a
des terroirs qui font la force de notre
pays
elle contribue à nourrir le reste du
monde autour de nous et donc nous avons
besoin de continuer à garder cette
agriculture qui est c'est vrai
exportatrices et c'est une des fiertés
de notre pays et on n'a pas besoin
seulement de ceux des fabricants
aujourd'hui on exporte beaucoup de
produits qui servent tout autour du
bassin méditerranéen alimenter des pays
qui ne sont pas en autosuffisance
alimentaire
ce qui est certain c'est que cette
transparence dont on aime parler elle
est très importante je me permets de
répondre à monsieur jadot qui m'avait
interpellé sur le sujet il ya quelques
jours les députés du rpt a compté moins
c'est l'idée pourquoi ils ont voulu
voter à bulletins secrets quand il
s'agit de voter
et bien justement les députés 2015 les
députés des républicains vont publier
leurs votes et ils ont comme vous savez
voter tous en faveur de ce régime de
transparence dans commun et choses sont
claires il n'y a aucune ambiguïté dans
notre famille politique en france nous
défendons absolument cette transparence
nécessaire maintenant moi je voulais
devenir un très bref instant si vous me
permettez sur le débat précédent je sais
que je ne vais pas me faire que des amis
mais c'est pourtant décisif il est clair
que la dette que nous léguerons à nos
enfants est aussi un problème peut-être
pas le seul problème mais c'est aussi un
problème est aujourd'hui je suis
d'accord avec vous pour dire qu'il faut
savoir investir sur les sujets
prioritaires mais ce qui nous empêche
d'investir
ça n'est pas le fait que nous soyons
contraints par la règle des 3% c'est le
fait que nous soyons incapables de
réformer nos politiques publiques et que
structurellement nous dépensons non pas
pour investir mais pour notre
fonctionnement plus que nous sommes
capables de 2,2 de dépenser d'apporter
comme contribution au budget de l'état
et donc oui un problème majeur sur le
sujet et je crois que malheureusement
même l'oiseau vous nous dites que vous
avez la certitude qu'il faut ne pas
accumuler la dette économique que nous
léguerons à nos enfants mais sur ce
sujet malheureusement rien n'a été fait
malgré une conjoncture économique
favorable au cours des deux dernières
années
rien n'a été fait pour faire baisser les
dépenses de l'état ce qui nous
permettrait ensuite d'avoir des marges
d'investissement sur l année il faut
être effectivement capable de se
protéger il faut sortir de la naïveté et
de ce point de vue là je me permets de
dire qu'on vient de vivre un dialogue
extrêmement éclairant parce qu'au fond
effectivement il ya en europe des gens
qui nous parlent aujourd'hui de l'europe
qui protège et qui en réalité
effectivement n'ont rien fait pour la
construire et bien sûr c'est vrai que
c'est un débat philosophique que nous
aurons sans doute ensemble je crois
qu'aujourd'hui sortir de la naïveté
c'est considérer qu'en effet il faut
mettre à la disposition nos services de
renseignements des moyens de connaître
ce qui se privent mais le monde que des
attentats sur le sol or il se trouve
qu'il y a des gens qui pendant des
années
ont voté contre les deux membres de ses
services de renseignement contre eux ce
qui était nécessaire pour mieux nous
protéger et je pense bien sûr
en effet pour un par exemple nous par
exemple je pense en particulier à ceux
qui ont voté contre le développement du
passenger name record le pnr qui permet
d'identifier ceux qui volent dans le
ciel européen
parmi eux il y a le groupe des libéraux
et puisqu'on parle de transparence
puisqu'on parle de transparence madame
loiseau il faut quand même que vous nous
disiez enfin avec qui vous allez siéger
demain parce que la transparence et pas
seulement dans les rendez-vous qu'on a
avec google ou avec apple la
transparence ça consiste aussi à dire
aux français avec qui on va défendre
avec le parti populaire vous allez et le
fides et des démocraties libérales
monsieur d'eau là avec ce qu'ils ont
fait avec normal elle fit date vous
l'avez que ce qu'ils ont fait on ne
regarde à la réflexion nous avons besoin
avec cette europe qui protège pendant la
moise au la question elle s'était posée
c'était il ya en effet y compris sur
notre liste des gens qui ont voté contre
le pnr aujourd'hui vous nous parler
d'europe qui protège est ce que vous
allez rejoindre demain le groupe aele 2e
je suis d'accord avec monsieur jadot sur
le fait qu'on a fait des folies
notamment effectivement dans
l'importation avec les états unis et je
suis d'accord avec lui sur un point nous
avons le devoir
mais pardon je ne suis pas nous sommes
dans la même situation groupe votre gros
plat bien moins que vous sur le décide
et hurle je lui dis que vous resterez
dans le groupe pourrait on pourrait
parler de beaucoup de choses de manière
très précise sur le sais pas je pense
qu'il y aurait à discuter de manière
précise d'ailleurs le groupe auquel
j'appartiens ou que je souhaite
rejoindre n'a pas voté de manière
unanime le ceta parce que les avis
étaient très partagés s'exciter mauvaise
chose de le voter
en tout cas je lui dis d'ailleurs à
titre personnel je n'aurais pas voté le
sénat
je dis simplement que il faut pouvoir
faire en sorte est dans le c'est à y
avait aussi des progrès de faire
reconnaître par exemple nous appellation
protégée et certains producteurs ont vu
leur appellation protégée reconnu à la
faveur de certains traités je crois que
si c'était seulement les traités de
libre échange qui avait menacé
l'écologie et l'économie de nos pays
aujourd'hui on n'en serait pas là la
plupart la plupart de la catastrophe
écologique vient évidemment du commerce
avec des états avec lesquels nous
n'avons pas d'accord de libre-échange
on peut penser par exemple
à des pays d'asie comme la chine
fondamental ce qu'effectivement on
impose notre souveraineté et nous
n'avons pas le droit de négocier
aujourd'hui avec un pistolet sur la
tempe
quant à même le zoo encore une fois
pardonnez moi mais là on est au coeur de
ce en même temps auquel on ne comprend
plus rien c'est à dire on peut pas dire
en même temps qu'on ouvre en effet ses
négociations dans le contexte on vient
de parler et qu'en même temps on dit et
qu'on promet qu'on ne signera pas de
traité alors n'en attrape ne s'est pas
d'abord une préoccupation très forte
dans nos campagnes c'est une
préoccupation très forte pour l'avenir
de notre monde lorsque les gorguillons
n'en dépend deuxièmement nous voulons
bien accueillir mais nous ne voulons pas
subir des flux migratoires qui ne sont
pas réguliers aujourd'hui et l'accueil
est devenu le vecteur d'une politique
d'immigration illégale qui est
totalement non maîtrisée nous le voyons
bien d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est à la
faveur de cette impuissance européenne
que prospère le business des passeurs à
travers la meilleure de la mer
méditerranée nous voulons mettre fin à
cette affirmation toute simple selon
laquelle mettre le pied sur le sol
européen même de manière illégale c'est
avoir beaucoup de chance de s'établir
durablement sur le sol européen
c'est le cas aujourd'hui et tant que ce
sera le cas nous ne pourrons pas lutter
efficacement contre cette ferraille
quand il met le pied sur le sol et bien
il faut que le demandeur d'asile puisse
effectuer sa demande en dehors du
territoire et mons majorité des gens qui
arrivent en europe 70% de ceux qui
demandent l'asile en france par exemple
ne sont pas éligibles à l'asile ils
viennent ici je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est un arrachement à cause des fausses
promesses que nous leur faisons lorsque
nous leur faisons croire qu'ils ont bien
sûr et bien je suis d'accord avec la
mine
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
et notre responsabilité encore une fois
c'est de pouvoir accueillir ceux qui ont
besoin de la solidarité mais de pouvoir
faire en sorte effectivement de mettre
fin à cette fausse promesse qui fait les
morts en méditerranée que je vais
l'année
elle est très vrai je sais pas ce qui
peut permettre de dire ça il suffit de
se référer à ce que laurent wauquiez a
pu écrire dans le livre qu'il avait
publiés ou effectivement il disait qu'il
fallait aller vers une plus grande
intégration en parlant de ces blocs de
coopération sont les frères audits sont
bagarrés je vous le dois garder je vous
reviens au dessus de leurs assises je
reviens bien enfin que chacun se réfère
à ce qui a été et je reviens nous nous
croyons qu effectivement on peut avancer
c'était la position qu'il défend des
avec des blocs de coopération qui
permette de sortir de la paralysie dans
laquelle effectivement à 27 il nous
arrive malheureusement de tomber lorsque
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
mais ce que je crois c'est
qu'aujourd'hui mais ont pas peur de le
dire l'europe est à la croisée des
chemins le break site est le symptôme
d'un désamour envers le projet européen
et qu'est ce qui cause ce désamour on
parle de démocratie
l'europe est le lieu qui a inventé la
démocratie et au fond je crois qu'il ya
un point de bifurcation très important
moi je ne crois pas effectivement à ce
grand métissage si c'est pour qu'il
aboutisse à la fin de la singularité des
peuples qui constitue leur opinion pas
un peuple européen et c'est ça qui est
magnifique en europe ya une pluralité de
peuples chacun avec leur culture leurs
références leurs manières de faire de la
politique et tout cela est connecté à
une même civilisation mais qu'on sur le
fond évidemment qu'on est tous d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut avancer vers une
meilleure connaissance mutuelle de
chacun et bien sûr je crois qu'on sera
tous d'accord ici pour dire on n'a pas
tous inventés mais qu'il faut développer
erasmus ce qui est certain en revanche
c'est que c'est un sujet politique
fondamentale et prenons le au sérieux si
l'europe suscite un tel désamour c'est
parce qu'elle est devenue pour beaucoup
de citoyens des peuples européens
le synonyme d'une dépossession
démocratique et nous ne pouvons pas
construire une europe fictive une europe
qui n'existerait que dans la queue de
caunes la tête de ceux qui décident sans
avoir été élu si le parlement européen
est une magnifique institutions c'est
parce que chaque pays d'europe envoient
ses représentants pour participer à ce
dialogue européen et je terminerai en
disant par lui n'aurait pas engrais en
exemple je permettais
du championnat seulement en disant qu'on
a un président de la république qui l'a
développé dans ses discours d'athènes ou
de la sorbonne dans plusieurs entretiens
l'idée que dans la mondialisation
l'échelle de nos états nations est une
échelle périmés terminé et qu'il faut
transférer comme le disait aurélien
tâche est encore récemment transféré
notre souveraineté à l'échelle
européenne
je vous renvoie et les patrons du
progrès de vote je vous renvoie à votre
à votre à la citation ce que je crois
moi c'est que nous avons besoin de
retrouver le sens de l'aventuré
européenne qui n'est pas celle née d'un
émiettement des nations qui se font la
guerre les unes contre les autres
ni non plus d'un empire qui voudraient
une forme ise chacun des peuples et je
crois et c'est un sujet majeur que pour
redonner confiance et le gouvernement
c'est le sujet de refaire de leur
enverrai raison d'occasion d'une
efficacité au service de nos logiciels
et n'ont pas leur place
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
rééquilibrage de la mondialisation et
c'est bien sûr nécessaire il faut tirer
les enseignements des erreurs du passé
il n'y aura pas de rééquilibrage de la
mondialisation sans frontières et je
crois que précisément c'est en risque en
reconstituant une vraie barrière
écologique à l'entrée du marché commun
c'est en apprenant de nouveau à
maîtriser effectivement les flux
migratoires pour accueillir ceux qui en
ont besoin
et bien c'est seulement à travers cela
que nous pourrons redonner un équilibre
la mondialisation et je crois en effet
c'est vrai que l'opposition entre
populiste et progressistes c'est une
position qui consiste à insulter des
gens qui vivent dans la papa